hey everybody is Jessie I'm a front-end
developer and this livestream is just
about showing people what I do so
whatever I happen to be working on at
this time of day
pretty much every day every weekday you
guys will see I want you to see all my
mistakes interruptions everything that
would happen in a normal day so this is
entirely unscripted and hopefully I'll
give you just a little glimpse of how at
least one front-end developer does his
work we are in the middle of a project
let me give you a quick recap I have
some info in the description for this
livestream and I also have some videos
I've done before this of one other video
on this channel free code camp and then
I have some other videos on my channel
and the link is in the description so we
have a partially finished website that
I'm going to take and finish but I'm
finishing it kind of in a different
format so the partially finished website
was built with Drupal we're going to
build this first it's just a static HTML
site and then eventually we're going to
convert that to react components and
we're going to render that server-side
and all the content is going to be
pulled in from WordPress through the
WordPress API so the react site will
exist on a different server from the
WordPress site and all the content will
come from there but we'll set all that
up and in the weeks to come for now we
need to get this site finished and ready
to go by Monday and the site actually
has to launch probably by the 13th so I
want to get it done by Monday so that we
have at least a few days for testing and
making
Changez if you have any other questions
about why we're doing this or background
for the project just put them in the
comments you can put them in the live
chat too but if there's a lot of people
in the latch at it's hard for me to keep
track of it so if I do miss your
question a lot of chat just put it in
the comments and then I'll get to it
later later on and I try to answer
everybody that their comments if you're
returning thanks for watching yesterday
the response was amazing I think we have
over 5,000 views on yesterday's video
and in 24 hours which is which is crazy
I live in a town that has maybe 18,000
people at most so to get 5,000 views in
a day on one of my videos it's just
really great and I had so much positive
feedback out of lots of thumbs up only
four thumbs down which is great if you
do thumbs down the video that's that's
fine with me but it would be cool if you
comment below and give me some feedback
so I can make this stream better I think
I mean I'm definitely welcome to
feedback I mean if you're mean about it
I mean that stinks but I'll I'll be able
to handle it
alright so enough introduction let's
just get to it here's what we've been
working on not a whole lot has changed
since yesterday at least visibly a lot
of the work that I've done has just been
on the mobile breakpoints making sure
the positioning is okay so PC is as I
shrink this down everything still looks
pretty good I added a slight border on
the bottom here to me that it just
looked a little bit better with that
border I'm not I'm not entirely sold on
it it might change let me know what you
think but it I was just used to seeing
this read up against the black and not
the black straight on the white so it it
just seemed nicer to have a little bit
of that red there and let me show you
this is an interior page and let me show
you on the home page we did make some
changes
so you still have this and this one is
actually growing on me I know I said
yesterday I might change it but you will
see I'm getting used to it and so it
might stay and then now once we get
smaller everything's still looking
pretty good when we get to a certain
point when the image and the font would
normally squish together we actually
just switch right back to that interior
header so it'll look the same as the
interior pages also if the screen is
short it will switch back but just in
case somebody has a really big phone and
they're in landscape mode it's possible
that their screen is would be wide
enough to not hit that break point but
still short enough so that the text
would actually be all up here the
tagline text and it would cover up the
logo so that's why I did you'd see here
in this media query this is how I did
that I said it max with inside of media
create 600 pixels and then a comma which
basically acts like an or if you're
writing a media query comma and then I
added that max height as well so I just
pop those in just on the few elements
the header the nav the logo the few
elements that needed to change you see
where the entire hero section is just
completely not even displayed and this
will help us too because we won't need
to make as many image sizes for all the
different screen sizes before I think we
had three or four different media
queries so we have all these different
image sizes now we won't have to mess
with that for today's video what I want
to work on is this page this team page
and as I said this is coming from a site
that is partially finished so let me
show you what we have to work with in
terms of the content that's already
there and it's not it's going to be a
little bit of a challenge okay so here's
the current team page from from the site
that's unfinished
I haven't
eruption so this is this is great from
me let me check it real quick sorry
Jesse you're active I'm really sorry
it's all I got
okay okay that's awesome I'm actually
glad interruption because that's like a
normal normal day you can't always just
have all your time to completely focus
on the code that was actually the head
of the department that I'm building this
site for so that was that was cool he's
a super nice guy he was really
apologetic for interrupting the
livestream okay so let's see this team
page so right now obviously we've
already changed the header you know this
this isn't going to be here I think this
is just too much stuff at the top
without seeing the content I'm not I'm
not entirely thrilled about this large
block of text I don't like the font it
just seems kind of difficult to read
maybe it just maybe it just needs to be
bigger or maybe not the white on the
dark red either way you know we're going
to change it we're probably not even
going to have this this block of text at
all or you know we definitely should cut
it down and break it up
I'm a big fan of really just minimal
text on pages and if you have some
interior pages that people expect have a
lot of text like a blog post people
expect to read that's fine but on a page
like this I don't think anybody would
expect to click on teams and the first
thing they get is a very large paragraph
what they're expecting is you know
probably this and their BIOS for the
people who are on the team this is
actually the person that just
interrupted the last shame accidentally
so I'm Adam he's what a nice is sketchy
over me so right now they have this this
kind of accordion there's a couple of
problems it's not it's not that easy for
the people that are in charge of the
content they don't have any experience
is with code and they're not going to
and that's fine but they need a way to
edit this easily and right now this
entire section here which goes on for a
while is all one big kind of WYSIWYG
section so in the the admin panel and
Drupal you know they literally had to
type out all of this and try to position
the images and it's hard enough to do
that if you know code you know let alone
if you're just trying to put this you
know put this in with with little
background I'm going to check the
lighter so I can see if I need any
answer anything yeah these will all be
available afterwards so somebody just
asked if if these will be available yeah
they are so the some of my previous ones
are available in my youtube channel and
that's linked in the description and
then yesterday I just started streaming
on free code camp so yesterday's is
available there so between the two
channels you'll be able to get
everything and if you have any other
questions just let me know in the
comments and I'll be happy to answer
them I'd like to do some shorter videos
that are pre-recorded and just kind of
explaining things in more depth and in
this format it's like oh you're welcome
and this format it's just kind of I
don't think it's the best format for
teaching I don't want to mislead anybody
by forgetting something or leaving it
out so I really like to take time to
kind of prepare and do a nice video edit
everything so if you know this would be
more of the teaching videos I'm sure
that and I hope that you'll learn
something with with the live streams but
this is just more kind of a glimpse into
my my day okay so the one problem with
this is the fact that it's not easy to
edit for the people that need to be to
update this content the second thing is
the the formatting is just not really
and this is it's just not you can see
it's it's not uniform okay we have all
the image sizes or all different sizes
some of them are aligned differently
there's a lot going on not only that
there's there's some just weird issues
when you click this you'll wind up in
the middle so I think I want to get away
from I want to get away from the
accordion I'm still thinking about maybe
some sort of accordion for mobile just
to cut down on the amount of scrolling
that somebody would have to do on a
phone but there's a lot of little BIOS
here in pictures a lot so we need some
way to be able to display these that's
that's not going to seem really
cluttered so here's my idea I was going
a little bit of sketching earlier and
was actually as to the meeting so if you
guys are work for a company or something
you have frequent meetings always bring
a sketch pad or something because you
get ideas and and I got some ideas for
this in the middle of meeting and I
sketched it out so you're obviously not
going to be able to see my sketch I
probably should have taken a picture of
it first to show you but I'll just
explain it what I'm kind of thinking is
maybe some horizontal like material type
design style cards actually I can't show
you an example I'm using the
materialized framework it's kind of like
you know bootstrap or foundation but
with a material design you'll kind of
build into it so let me show you how
they do their horizontal cars and this
is kind of a newer thing when I first
started using materialized they didn't
have horizontal cards actually had to
get a kind of adjust the cards that they
did have to make them but then they
added horizontal cards and they're
awesome so this is the documentation for
materialized so this one I'm talking
about a horizontal card so we'll have an
image here and then a little bit of text
and in this case they have a link here
I'm thinking for right now
maybe the link would actually open up a
modal that would have more information
because we can't possibly put all that
text that's in the bio here and that
link I think there's a possibility there
could be YouTube videos for a lot of
these
team members at some point on the road
so the modal would also work for that as
well you can definitely do a YouTube
embed in a modal and and that would work
I think that would that would look fun
so for now that's the plan we're going
to put those all those images and
actually I'd like to make the images
square if I could I think that's the
only way I'm going to be able to get all
these images the same size the the
chances of actually finding pictures
that are all the same or taking pictures
for all these people or just it's not
going to happen not all of them are even
here on campus so we just can't do it
but I think if we go square you know
every one of these pictures could
possibly be edited to be a square and at
least show somebody's face so that's
what we're going to go with I just hope
that they're big enough so that I could
get a decent sized square but the
horizontal cards as you can see are they
aren't really that big they don't have
to be that big so that's the plan so
we're going to grab some of this code
for a horizontal card and let's put it
in a page to see how it looks and see
how it looks when we put a bunch of them
in there just to get a feel for like
will this actually work okay somebody
asked how long I've been using
materialized framework I've actually
been using materialized for about two
years I think about two years so when I
first started using it I wasn't exactly
sure if it was production ready or not
there were definitely some live sites
that were using it I never had any
problems any major problems with
anything you know breaking there was
some like on edge cases mostly having to
do with putting like a lot of text as
the title in a card or something and
having some so weird things happen when
it wrapped onto another line but all in
all I think it's a good framework the
only thing that I don't like about it
now that it really it's it's part of a
lot of frameworks is that it requires
jQuery and so
I'm no problem with jQuery I use it on a
lot of my sites but I'm starting to get
more into react and from everything I've
read about reacts you really shouldn't
use jQuery with it it's not that it
won't work but it's better not to use it
I'm not a react expert but it has to do
with the way react tracks the Dom it has
this virtual Dom and if you change the
Dom with jQuery after the fact that it
loads it can mess up react to them so
that's I don't know any more in detail
about it but so at some point I would
really love to I don't kind of convert
materialized framework to react
components and rewrite everything and
just vanilla JavaScript I think there
are already some people trying to do
that so maybe I'll just check out their
repo and try to contribute to that so
someday someday hopefully I'll get that
done but for now I'm just I'm going to
keep working with it it just saves so
much time now they put in a lot a lot of
work into this this framework and it
works well
so we asked why am i doing so many divs
yeah that's just that's just how the
framework is with with all these divs so
when you're using a framework you can't
you're kind of locked into how they have
things set up I don't know if I would
use that many gives if I was doing it
from scratch but I've it's actually not
that bad compared to how many divs are
used in the like this current site that
I'm using kind of as my example to go
off of there's a lot of divs in there
all right so let's put this in and I'm
going to put it I'd like to see what it
looks like on both these backgrounds on
the white background and on the red
background so I'm going to put it in
both those places so here's here's our
HTML for that page you see from
yesterday actually went through and
duplicated this and all the pages for
the main menu just so you know
have them be able to to work on them on
okay all right so this section let's pop
in let's pop this in here pop one of
these in I guess I didn't need this
header okay and let's go ahead and put
this let's put another one down here
whoops I didn't grab the columns too
sorry if this is confusing to you you
know there's there's kind of a lot this
is kind of the grid system the column
system for materialised check out I have
a link in the description so if you
check out their documentation it should
make a lot more sense all the source
code for this is on github as well for
the project that I'm doing so you can
follow along I'll try to keep that I'll
try to push changes right after I'm done
with the video and then that way it'll
be all up-to-date for you and if you if
you want to you know submit a pull
request or something to contribute to
the project that would be awesome too
I'm definitely up for that alright so
let's see what the scale is okay um I
mean let me change the columns I wanted
to see how this looked like side by side
so we have if we change this to m6 this
is out of a twelve column layout so if
we give it m6 that means on a
medium-sized screen it'll take up six of
those twelve columns so this should be
side by side okay side by side and I
once again I forgot to take out this
header okay all right so we have these
side by side it's not that this this is
a little bit of problem though
see how this image looks when when we
have too much text if we're going to do
the horizontal cards like this we got to
make sure we've got to make sure there's
definitely a limit on how much text can
be in here to make sure we don't I don't
like that at the bottom that makes it
look kind of like it's it's broken
so we'll have to watch out for that I'll
work on that at some point later today
just to check it but if if we can get it
to the point where whenever we're not
seeing that gap at the bottom I think
these will work this will allow us to do
two columns instead of one long column
for all the team members we can I think
we can alternate the white sections and
the red sections to differentiate
between all those different categories
that we saw let me go back to our
example so we had that you know four
categories here so I think we could do
like you know we could definitely do the
four categories the only one I'm worried
about is the second one I think there's
like 37 different people that we need
two different BIOS we need to put in
that's a lot it's a lot of scrolling
okay so here's what we'll do right now
I'm going to copy these a little bit I
said I want to check out how they look
on this background and I just want to
get a feel for how did these stack I'm
going to chain move the screen in a
little bit normally um I wouldn't be
doing making so many design decisions as
I'm developing this is kind of a special
case this project has a super tight
timeline and I didn't even know at the
beginning the week that I'd be working
on it so that's why we're combining
those steps it's usually better to kind
of have the design more lock down at
first before you do this I don't
I'm doing it like this but sometimes
it's you waste a little bit of time
trying things that end up not working
and if you would have just maybe planned
them out in Photoshop or sketch or
whatever the new thing adobe has that's
that's like sketch I can't really what
is called you plant it on something like
that first it could save you might be
able save you some time I guess it just
depends on whether you're faster with
code or faster with Photoshop all right
so let's just grab some of these and and
copy and paste them just to give us a
more realistic look for how this will be
when we get a lot of a lot of these in
here I'm just going to pop in so that
was really quick but what I did is is I
copied the whole row so this div is a
row div and then inside each row we have
two columns if we can I'd love to go on
a bigger screen maybe even up to three
columns if it'll work so maybe we can
test that out maybe not today because we
have about seven minutes left maybe I'll
try it out later and show you tomorrow
if it worked and where's the red section
I want to get into under that red
section up here there we go and let's
pop in a couple of these in there as
well it should look about the same in
the red section I'm just what I'm really
worried about is just that white right
up against the red and just just kind of
seeing if it works sometimes you just
don't know until you get it on the page
whoa okay well this is cool
somewhere I have it set to have white
text inside which makes sense because
you want the white text against the red
background so that's an easy fix we'll
scroll up to the top and materialize
there we go to this class called white
text that's one of their helper classes
they're building the framework that is
probably where we're getting that style
from so if I take that out there we go
we have the text with modders yeah I've
had a couple people are asking will this
be recorded
the video gets automatically uploaded to
the channel really kind of minutes after
the livestream ends so if you jumped in
the middle you know just check out the
the recording of it later I mean it it's
usually like five minutes or less the
seems like the video is posted okay and
like I said earlier in case you didn't
catch that if you're asking something a
live chat and I miss it because it is a
little bit hard to keep up with the live
chat and do the code just ask it in the
comments because I'll read the comments
afterwards and I'll try to get back to
you as soon as I can okay
this doesn't look terrible I really kind
of don't like that it's so uniformed all
the way down I was a little bit afraid
of that I think there needs to be
something to break this up so we need
some sections my my first idea is this
all this big block of text here that we
kind of don't want in a big block maybe
rework the text and actually my boss is
great at this he always handles tech
stuff for me which is awesome because I
don't want to deal with tech stuff and
it usually takes me a long time maybe we
can say okay we want like three sections
you want this broken out into three
sections we can do a much bigger font
maybe like a responsive font so it the
font size changes with screen size I
really like that materialise has that
built in as well and then we can have
maybe some some different colored
sections in between possibly you know we
could possibly have all these cards on
white sections and then the text on the
red sections or we could do maybe some
sort of parallax section with with an
image that might work to break things up
we can actually test that out right now
let's here's a good good way to test
this will be to let's grab
all of this that we just put here all of
these rows hopefully I can I can catch
the right spot here section yeah this is
it hopefully I can grab yeah
okay pretty much you have everything I
got one extra did that I didn't need so
let's just add that back in and for now
we'll just let's pop in an H and H tune
and just be text and we'll pop in a
paragraph tag and just put we should be
able to
let's give it a class of flow text
within materialized this will give us
kind of a responsive effect on our font
it will change font sizes and I think if
there we go I'm using Adam as my cutted
editor and I think this is built-in it's
possible it's from some plug-in I loaded
a long time ago I forgot about but if we
can just type in lorem and hit tab and
it gives us some lorem ipsum text wow
that's a lot okay so that's cool we can
see the lorem ipsum and here's what I
want to do I'm just going to take this
section we'll leave that heading and I
want to keep that heading in actually
we'll leave that whole row so is the row
stuff and we'll pop in all that stuff
all those cars that were the read
section and now they're going to be in
the section on the top and that'll let
us see what it looks like when we have a
divider okay um that's not terrible it
doesn't look too and we took out the
white text class so let's put that back
in I'm somewhat new to live streaming so
if you couldn't already tell and what I
found over the last couple of weeks is
that you miss little things that you
would probably never miss normally when
you're trying to talk at the same time
as as code so I'm not quite such a noob
as I have here today I have one eye when
I live steering okay that does break
things up a bit I don't know if you guys
can see it but it seemed to me yeah it
seems to me like it's not quite as it's
just monotonous and repetitive okay
I'm happy enough with that that I think
it's worthwhile to go through and
actually
you know maybe try out three columns try
to try to get this to the image to
always look good put in maybe some a few
real images from from the ones that
we're actually going to use yeah I think
that's worth whoa all right so I'm
coming to the end of my stream got about
a minute left oh thanks I'm getting some
real positive feedback there
thank you and I'm serious if you have
any tips for me you know I'm for my code
I always been trying to get better and
for my live streams I I'm really new so
I know I can get better at this so I
really love the positive feedback but I
welcome some criticism as well I have
one question here that I think I can
answer before we run out of time
and it's can you make a video how to set
up the Adam editor for most efficiency
okay I can make a where do you tip I
must I don't have a tip button right now
maybe I actually purposely did not want
to seem like I'm trying to do this for
any type of money at all at first uh
maybe one day if it starts taking up a
lot of my time it might make more sense
to ask for tips
but right now I'm actually doing this at
my regular job my boss is awesome and he
realizes how how much value that there
isn't something like this so I just
wouldn't feel right getting paid on top
of my normal wage for doing this but if
I start doing more videos I definitely
will as for the video about Adam I'm
writing it down right now and I'm not
sure that I have the best set up I'm
there's I'm fact I know there's got to
be people that have better more
efficient setups than me but I will
definitely share the way I have it set
up and maybe maybe that will help but
maybe you can improve on it should do a
mobile-first
yeah you're right about the mobile first
sorry I'm going over a little bit as
trying to answer some more questions
here the the comment was most users will
be your website through mobile instead
of a desktop or laptop
this is this is kind of I'm really glad
that you said that in this case some of
the people that I'm working with for
this site we're kind of trying to get a
feel for the audience and there's been
some talk that the audience isn't going
to be a mobile-first audience is going
to be an older audience but I agree with
you I think the even if it is an older
audience we still should do a mobile
first so normally that is how I do
things in this case I didn't partially
because I'm kind of working from an
already partially completed site but
you're right normally I would do all the
Styles focused really small and then
kind of go up maybe I'll switch up to
that but that's definitely a good tip I
highly recommend that if you're starting
a project from scratch do everything
with the mobile in mind and then then
start to expand the screen and say okay
what else can we add now and then that
way your users won't feel like mobile as
an afterthought you know you put most of
your thought into the mobile experience
and the desktop will feel really clean
and not cluttered because you know you
all your content is off the most for
mobile so anyway I don't want to make
this video too long and be intimidating
for people to watch it again thanks for
all the feedback if you have any more
questions leave them in the comments
check out I have some links down below
for some of the tools that I'm using and
places where you can see the code and
everything and I'll be back tomorrow at
2 p.m. I'm going to do the stream on
free code camp channel again if I do
some of those videos like on Adam or
some other things some short tutorial
videos I'll probably throw those on my
my personal channel and so thanks thanks
for all the feedback and everything else
getting throughout the video I'll see
you tomorrow